i think we're standing on a genuine
precipice
and
it's getting worse all the time
because of this misunderstanding
misinterpretation of our societies
and what i mind is that
this is the best chance we have
you know
there isn't another option
we don't have
for instance if we're going to go back
to this
line of racial segregation this time
enforced by so-called anti-racists
we go back to hell
absolute hell
and you can feel it daily what's eroding
is
the settlement that we had
on that you know sam harris and i have
said before you know we had hoped to
arrive at a stage where skin color was
as unimportant as hair color
and now these people come along it's
like having a
ginger separatist movement you know i i
mean
to decide we should only speak about
hair color for the rest of our lives
then creates countervailing forces and
much more but it's like the settlements
that we were hoping to head towards are
being pulled apart
by people who seem gleeful at pulling
away the threads of our society they
seem positively gleeful about it and
that goes back to your point about
reason
that's because there is
an instinct that drives people to
destroy
you know it's
it's there throughout human nature the
instinct to destroy is very strong the
high octane of enjoyment of destruction
isn't it also because it's easy douglas
it's far easier to destroy than it is to
create that's right that's one of the
central burkina insights
um
yes
you you can pull pull a thing down in a
second and it takes a long time to build
it up you can destroy a building or a
statue in no time at all it might take
somebody an entire lifetime to create it
and so we find ourselves in
a very sub-optimal condition because the
desire to pull down is clearly rife but
maybe this is an evidence that people
have to endlessly relearn the same
lessons you know there's a line in
elliot and murder in the cathedral he
says
men do not
men do not learn very much
except that from generation to
generation the same things happen again
and again
men learn little from others experience
you're
sounding very apocalyptic daedalus
and i don't blame you because i don't
disagree with you and the question that
francis and i really both want to ask is
do you think we are past the point of no
return now
no i don't
i'll tell you why
these are the circumstances outside
but the circumstances outside are always
bad
they're always bad now there's
particular peaks to the mania
i've been reading quite a lot about
revolutions recently for
obvious reasons
um and
it's just so striking the extent to
which this is
it's just what happened in 1789 it's
just what happened in 1917.
i was reading the other day an account
of
the days after the revolution in 1917
vincent petersburg
when you know law and order of course is
all fallen apart but people are sort of
starting to police themselves and sort
of quasi
no one quite knows because of course the
revolution was meant to bring peace but
no one actually focused on any of the
details just like in 1789 so nobody
knows what to do when things go wrong
like crime and there's a description an
incredibly haunting description i read
of on a tram in saint petersburg in 917
a rather well-dressed woman
and there's a rather well-dressed man
near standing near her and
he um she starts screaming she thinks
he's stolen her purse and everyone gets
interested and they start
finding out what's happening the man
insists he hasn't stolen her purse
and a couple of men with a sort of
self-appointed police at this point
decided he must have done clearly and
they take him off the town and shoot him
in the head
and they get back on the tram and the
woman finds that the purse has fallen
down the lining of her coat
and then they have a problem of course
so they take her off the tram and shoot
her in the head as well
it's a russian way mate what can i say
that's how it's effective
you know and
that's what happens
in revolutions that's what happens when
everything starts to break down that's
what's happened in kenosha briefly
that's what happens when you know one
person thinks he's going to go and
protect a shop
and then gets appears
one particular case that i'm thinking
about obviously appears to have been
separated from other people and then the
people who are the protesters and
recognize who he is and then before you
know it he ends up shooting three people
dead
you know that's what happens what's
happening in portland people being
dragged out of their cars and smashed in
the head or shot
that's what happens when everything else
breaks down but
so we might be in one of these periods
and it might get a lot worse yet
or
it could get better but the reason for
optimism on it
is
that this
is what history is always like
and we've had a very blessed time in our
lives so far
and i don't need to tell you to
all of us
here
know something a lot of people outside
this room don't
which is we're the luckiest
damn people in history
and luckier than any of our forebears
and luckier than we have any right to
expect
but it was always like this in history
and the thing that's most important the
thing in a way i
think is most important for us all to be
thinking about and the people watching
particularly young people watching to be
thinking about is this
it's always like this to some extent and
don't
wait
for more optimal conditions before you
do what you're meant to be doing in your
life
because the optimal conditions will not
be arriving
and it's a great point you make and do
you think part of the reason we've come
to this point is because of cowardice
and i use that word in its truest sense
of a lot of the mainstream media in
particular the left the center left who
seem unwilling to stand up
and say to these people you may be on
your on our side you may be on our side
politically but what you are doing is
fundamentally wrong and destructive yes
and they or they want power more than
they want truth
but sorry to interrupt douglas i mean i
don't think you can lay the blame for
that only with the left i mean look at
boris johnson on on blm he he did very
little said almost nothing yeah to to to
to
his to tackle there were two excuses for
that which i don't like at all
one is that he was still ill yeah
possibly in that case somebody else from
the government had to make a stand
the second is that some people say this
is a typical boris johnson tactic that
his desire tends to be to wait till
there's massive overreach by his
opponents and then say
something if it's not overreached when
the cenotaph is being attacked i don't
know what is you know or when the
winston churchill statue is being
attacked but your point still stands
which is cowardice yeah is that yes
cowardice a desire for quiet life
um but as i say also
prioritizing the search for power over
truth
you know the new york times which is
just a lost publication now clearly
um
you know has has deliberately inverted
the nature of these riots as pro-trump
supporters become more violent
protesters have to work out how they
should react was one of the headlines
something like that one of the headlines
they did the other day
as if the sort of black bloc protesters
just sitting around a rather a
contemplative body these are these uh
protesters
uh
so yes
those people want to be in power more
than they seek truth
which is a calculation that will come
back and bite them at some point
and hope it bites them fast but probably
not
um
but to come back to this point
it's it's really crucial i think we
started to bear this in mind we've
spoken before about the over emphasis of
politics in all of our lives the way in
which it's become almost a full-time
occupation for too many people you know
um
and
i mean
i think that when politics is gets as
bad as particularly america now is
people start to wonder what they can do
and other than voting there's not very
much that most people can do
um
other than influencing the people around
them what i'm worried about is this
endless opportunity cost you know
park rose and lindsay say in their book
at one point what would have happened if
the academics doing all this complete
wank about you know intersectionalism
and you know
comparative feminist theory and the
intersections with disability and fat
studies what if they'd have done
something meaningful with their time
what if they'd studied something that
was of importance what if all of that
brain power and it must by now be a
considerable amount of brain power had
been
expended on a worthwhile problem well
maybe we'd be a bit further forward what
of those people brought us i thought
nothing
but now it turns out it's worse than
nothing it's an actually malevolent
malignant thing that they have been
injecting into the thought of our
society so again
just to come back to this point
what do we do as individuals about this
we all have a limited amount we can do
in our personal lives in terms of trying
to correct untruths
correct false narratives
but other than that i think it's a very
important message we remember you you
shouldn't put off what it is you should
be doing with your life nevertheless
[Music]